[Applause]
[Music]
just up in every new york is really
none in the back a new free the day and
a new there breaks a self
shipping about all that t bridge road
safety king him take the frost moment
and who the new york stock exchange  in the
access to architecture history
we want to wall street mid the room and
breaking and other glass ceiling light
to the drive-in show and biological
server and never get some other in for
always die queen emmaschool the new
york stock exchange home
since ninety-  nine die for your first
memory of new york stock exchange it
would be nice engineering will ns golf
target had a stans and the the bottom
internship of anne training for
is louis sachar de albus ouwens and
energy in the tendon
to your in-laws chic lyme drinks
on  wall street
deposit is a for organ specialist
working korea
well how that for you have that new york
stock exchange internship
stacy king him something first female
president in it would  you never about man
my mother may have very high profile
wal in in global rooms in in the hairdresser
markets and so offer face of that is
to a team and i must now fourstar the
new moon of view wim and yes slot
crime like a de  norwegian and eyeliner
surprising and there's a huge number
laminate
kind had the for when one moment
bodewes is just a little bit was a stairs mind for
more tanks in large marconi games te
muriel siebert back in 1916 7
siebert has the way the coming de frost
moments energy  at the new york stock
exchange
chica solution and cheap air tickets
puncher to be
how men and the first line people say yes
and
no already in and idea should your family start
in there was a there was quite a lot of support
for having her nursery that day  hardwork
and sola settings personal with after all
heavy foil opens solitary phone booth
number 5
edgar mitchell edison my next your van
number five was the manager and the
litterly pixel endorse the tendency
coaches the holding  promise training for
in 2005
i ordered from the actors he wo
n't fit in your channel subscribe bums
and produce
ever the queen is one die oil
prominent to a wall street on the move
read the blog here 4 les carroz station
is heading from miss bart  in from the
charging bol
tuber to purge in from the new york stock
exchange and what exactly is the
greatest ai my lover of finchy
challenges
korper de merry go to the bad in order to have
a new block and amber women in the
korra versus  ios last and 5% the fortune
500 m in one and not necessarily growing
the family connected her life function
is taking on the world and cheese to
free the there already
haircut in my talking with her she took a
sabbatical by one her time there has
free  to the culinary school kitchen
frenzy is like
the wall street frenzy in the the tiger guise
of communication must on teamviewer
things liberal the firekeeper check out
the mercy bertha was a wheel pioneer on
wall street machines is  roger head down
and charge l&r imprint